the principal I represent has an offer  for you  death must look like an accident  your specialty oddly the Doudna skills  I've been waiting too long to get even  again you have 36 hours to eliminate all  the targets on this list  there's no sign of the intruder mr.  Adams  that's because he's sitting right in  front of me here in the safe room  jackoff lets them all live simply like  to die and see you up to lift up can't  testify  I'll help you avoid an accident were you  ever non you'll have to die imagine what  God would be so Devon berry  relentless earthy so my  you  put your hands up the soul of our  country is as  the purge targets the poor and the  innocent the center is going to win  she's going to mcgrill changes to it is  a night that is